[Music]
we want liberty
we want justice
let lives matter
[Music]
it would be utopia if
race was not a part of
the remarks the actions in society but
the fact is this
race is a social
uh construct but racism is very much
real and tangible and dangerous the fact
of the matter is that racism exists
discrimination exists and biases exist
if we do not acknowledge it or measure
it we cannot take action on it
and to ignore race is to ignore
uh the stories and journeys of each and
every african-caribbean asian minority
ethnic people
and communities and we have to accept
and acknowledge the journeys
biases has consequences
and if we do not recognize that
we cannot measure it and we cannot
mitigate against it
and that is why we're going on this
journey at the moment it's very
difficult at the moment for some it's a
very uncomfortable conversation for some
it's a very confronting and challenging
conversation for some but it's a
necessary conversation
what surprises me that people are
surprised they're surprised at the lived
experiences of people of color and i
often wonder why are they surprised it's
because
they live in a different world in a
different bubble where
they are not subjected to everyday lived
racism just because of the color of
one's skin
so i would say for those who
try their best to pretend that they
don't see color
they will often then fail to see the
injustices that comes with being a
person of color
and if we're going to move beyond that
we have to just talk frankly about it
france has a position where they
have eradicated race from their
constitution but that in itself causes
problems
when i've had conversations with the
ministers around kovitt 19 for example
and how they're measuring the success
they're unable to break it down because
they don't measure
[Music]
they're seeing race rights on their
streets that how else do they explain it
because they don't measure the housing
situation they can't measure it they
can't tell you what's actually happening
so in effect this utopian world which
one day i hope
uh might exist where people are judged
um as martin luther king said by the
content of their character rather than
the cut of their skin i do not think
that will happen
um in my lifetime and i think in order
to progress we have to confront the
injustices that currently exist
we have to talk about it and we have to
stand up against it and it will take a
conservative effort to ensure that that
happens and i think that you're either
part of the
journey for change
or you're part of a system that wants to
keep the status quo
[Music]